hey backer Roseanne's which and hoffman
and so you were on the rubin report this
week
and you haven't been on in a couple
months because you went to new york and
you've done something new with your
fashion that i wanted to lead into a
discussion weren't ties now yes I've
taken to wearing a tie I don't know why
I just decided I like the way it looks
yeah it looks a little sharp so like I
don't have like the low slung tie but
yeah I've been wearing like shirts and
proper ties and bow ties and boleros and
this kind of more maybe masculine look
but I have a feminine look otherwise
like long hair and a curvy body so maybe
I don't know what's giving a little bit
more doing what feels yeah I just really
dresses and you have big boobs or people
always think you're trying to emphasize
your boobs so I'm just kind of so you're
trying not that you're actually tying
something to hide you're really hiding
my boobs I'm just not trying to wear
like the most feminine frilly dress
anymore fair enough so Jen was on the
show this week and a lot of the comments
in the YouTube videos were that she
looks lesbian he or Daiki or something
like that people who are now saying shut
up you stupid Dyke or you would say that
because you're a lesbian
all of a sudden into any opinion I had
there was now this shade of sexuality
put on it that my sexual preference ma
I'm wearing a tie therefore I must be a
lesbian therefore my opinion of course
would be this right now you were saying
that you've not only never been called a
lesbian for not that there's anything
wrong with that right no I've never been
called a legend before except for like
actions like if I've made out with okay
then you're you know but just by having
lesbians lesbians you know yeah but what
have you been called before cuz this is
where I think it's kind of interested
this is what's interesting yeah
previously especially when I dress very
feminine I was immediately called like
just you stupid [ __ ] I'm called a [ __ ]
oh I it was always very like derogatory
or that it was mostly sexualized so the
more I'm wearing something that is
definitely would be associated with not
just a woman but very feminine the more
the comment section and more people that
have added me on Twitter or even in
person and in life when they've been
upset with me the comments of a new
horror you [ __ ] or your this and the
second them look got a little bit more
masculine immediately we shut up your
lesbian right so I think this is really
fascinating because I I saw the tie and
it didn't strike me as a lesbian or not
lesbian or whatever it is cool but I
think it's guy yeah it's kind of it
strikes me as like comic sort of yeah I
feel like maybe that's more of it I
think of it as like a Paula Poundstone
thing well actually she is
I started thinking about that most
people I know that are famous lesbians
are comedians and they're those Sarah
Silverman drops of tie too but she gets
the same comments like shut up you Dyke
and I'm like but she's not a lesbian
right so it's funny because I have many
lesbian friends and had a lot of
lesbians on the show obviously they are
come in all shapes and sizes much like
there's all kinds of black people and
all kinds of white people and all kinds
of Christian people etc I've heard
people say about you I've heard them say
Oh Dave Reubens gay he doesn't seem gay
you don't know I get that yeah
constantly he doesn't seem gay which I
don't know what that means like what are
you supposed to be doing
yes seeming gay I don't know like this
is it like I'm gay I don't know how much
gay or I could get than this right now
right it's just people want to apply
whatever immediate image they have
towards you a stereotype obviously but
when it gets strange is when people
start to decide that you must feel a
certain way because like there's people
that maybe assume you're straight rather
assume you're gonna have certain
opinions about something right but now
yeah it's just like the anger has been
toward if that's what struck me about it
it was the anger now became about being
a lesbian before the anger was about me
being so straight that I it must be a
[ __ ] who just loves dicks Miami you
know what I don't think is funny is that
you know most of our audience I would
assume I pretty sure is pretty liberal
especially on the social stuff at least
right sir I think they're pretty liberal
in general but at least on the social
stuff so it's like when they then would
look at you and then make that judgement
just on and then somehow they're they're
attacking you on that like you're saying
it obviously in a knife yeah that's a
bad thing
nobody was point you Dyke like that also
seems like particularly odd to me that
even for liberal people still the idea
of because I believe me I get it
all the time laugh bag bag bag and then
the other half go oh I didn't know he
was gay but like that idea that still
this sexuality is still used against you
and used to make assumptions about what
your opinions are gonna be about things
and I feel like if you consider like
this is like you're a straight woman who
identifies as a woman and you're on air
and you dress like a woman you're either
a [ __ ] or you're stupid yeah usually
generally not everyone there's gonna be
people commenting going oh why do you
think that about everyone I'm not
saying everyone I'm saying when people
decide to get ugly or judgmental that's
a go-to so I just want to put that out
there too so people at first aren't like
well everyone isn't coming out you in it
fine I got it but it's a strange show it
just flipped immediately right is that
can I accessorize with the tie it went
from being either like in the anger went
from being dumb or hoary to suddenly
like well gay this is one of the things
where I definitely like have a lot of
empathy for women in media in general
because if you think about it like all
the Fox News women we all know this like
you can just google it they all look
exactly the same they're all tanned
exactly the same they all wear the same
you know shirt sleeveless whatever and
then the guys all wear suits and across
news altogether and always think it's so
funny like all the women have to wear
they have to show their arms and part of
what they do but imagine if a Wolf
Blitzer showed up in a tank top
you'd barf right to be like that rebut
that standard really does even in 2015
it's still hugely exist so briefly when
I was in news I was a reporter and like
really briefly an anchor that was when
it was just shifting from women had to
be so covered up where you couldn't even
show your arms right and you have short
hair if you wanted to be a woman in news
they've advised you to cut your hair no
longer than shoulder length at all being
very blonde was frowned upon and they
wanted you really buttoned up they're
trying to make you look like the male
anchors then when they realize that you
can kind of like feminized this and get
more men to tune in and more women that
would want to be like the female anchor
that's when you started to see the
sleeves with the really toned arms and
the hair getting longer and I'm like the
sexy anchor words in Fox it's more like
the it's like they're going in between
milf and I don't know what kind of
anchor yeah I'm not sure what kind of
anchor anyway can you get your news from
women that are wearing sleeved shirts
the lesbians look a certain way give me
one more question here do
man finish me strong game you guys have
to wear a certain thing it might is my
sure to loose right now let me know in
the comments right down below and don't
forget to subscribe